voici l'une des lettres adressées au
président de la république signé par des
élus de la région et datée de mars 2007
un courrier qui tire la sonnette
d'alarmé sur une possible fermeture de
site à cause d'un manque de commandes
brutes en chacun avait parfaitement
conscience des difficultés que pouvait
rencontrer
alstom sur la question de la production
de locomotives en france la décision de
monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de
renouveler le parc de tnt via un appel
d'offres et non par extension des
contrats créés cadre ces décisions a
considérablement fragilisé les sites de
production d'alstom transport et ses
milliers d'emplois et précis fermeture
du site de belfort
aucune information n'avait été mise à
l'information du gouvernement sur cette
fermeture j'entendais hier arnaud
montebourg dire l'état n'a pas fait ce
qu'ils devaient faire mais l'état n'est
pas là en situation de responsabilité ce
n'est pas une annonce de l'état
les acheteurs publics doivent apprendre
à être des patriotes et c'est la
responsabilité des dirigeants de l'état
que de leur apprendre ou de l'échangé
lorsqu'il n'en sont pas capables marque
quand on est actionnaire on anticipe les
choses on les voit venir ça ce pas été
improvisée ça fait un moment qu'on en
parle donc le gouvernement l'a a manqué
de pertinence
j'ai passé une commande de 3 milliards
8,3 milliards 800 millions à un milliard
huit pour un numéro vert
voilà le syndicat les transports qui ont
résidé président de région deux cent
quarante rames 3 milliards 8 de commande
pour un rer nouvelle génération qui
devra être évidement la vitrine
eh bien il ya un appel d'offres qui est
en cours qui est passé par la sncf c'est
la sncf qui s'occupe du rer e et du rer
d arthur ce contrat c'est la région ile
de france qui aura le dernier mot
mais cette piste est plutôt incertaine
car c'est un groupe ferroviaire espagnol
qui serait le mieux placé
mais quand on voit tout ce qu'il
actualise et burkina
tout ça ça donne envie de je pense que
les voilà il ya là le conseil d'état qui
est sage je crois qu'il faut mettre des
choses au bon endroit
ça y est je suis candidate à la primaire
de la droite et du centre
j'étais en train de réfléchir à tout ça
je suis en train de vous écrire mais
puis-je me suis dit que j'allais plutôt
vous le dire directement la gauche peut
mourir mais moi comme vous je veux
qu'elles vivent et je vous le dis
simplement
peut-on se permettre dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois devant
les français dans la situation que nous
connaissons avec les risques que je
viens d'évoquer le luxe de la division
merci à ceux qui m'ont parrainer mais
pas soutenu merci à ceux qui m'ont
soutenu et papa et les bref merci à tous
ceux qui m'ont porté un bonze campagne
pour les parrainages et puis merci merci
à jacques séguéla je serai sarkozy je
voterai pour elle